>> Hi, I'm Eric Durand. I'm a
computational biologist here at 23andMe. I've been with
the company for about two years now. And
I'm mostly working on their ancestry products which
range from a variety of different problems. before that, I was a post-doc at UC
Berkeley for another two years and even before
that I was a PhD student in France.
>> We really want
to know from a computational biologist is, how
do you determine IBD, or identity by descent.
>> Yeah, so first maybe we should define exactly what IBD, or
identity by descent, is. So, IBD is something that refers to a
chunk of continuous DNA and we say that two individuals share a chunk
of DNA identical by descent if this chunk has been inherited through
a common ancestor without recombination. It means that
you inherited these segments from the common ancestor however
far back it was in the past and
it was never broken by a recombination event during
meiosis. So if you want the simplest example
of, of identity by descent maybe is between a
parent and his child, where because of the way,
if I refer you back to high school biology,
because of the way chromosomes are inherited a child will inherit one chromosome
exactly from each of his parents. And so a child is 50% identical by
descent with his parent. And he is, in this case a common ancestor
is the parent, himself. And the child is 50% IBD with, with the parent.
>> And so it doesn't matter how big the segment is.
The segment could be the whole length of the chromosome itself or
anything shorter than that.
>> Exactly. So if you only look one generation back in time the, the
segment will cover a full chromosome in the child. So, full chromosome in the
child will be identical by descent with his parent. If you go one more
generation with, with a child is about
25% IBD with each of his four grandparents.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But there already, the 25% is only approximate and it can vary.
You can be more IBD, you can share more IBD with
one grandparent than with another, just because of the way recombination occurs.
>> I see. So, there may be an average
an average IBD but it doesn't have to be exact because, like
you said, the recombination doesn't happen in the same place every time.
>> Exactly. And also because of our ability to detect it, there is some error,
some statistical error around the estimation of IBD, which in the end will lead
to slightly different estimate. But it should
be pretty close to 25%. And the further
back you go in time and the
more variation you have between those percentages and
also the shorter the segments become and the harder
they become to, to detect. So if you want to
relate IBD and IBS for example, the main diff, difficulty
with IBD I guess it's two-fold. It's first, we do
not observe the recombination process. It would be great if
we had that in some kind of black box or,
or records that tells us where this is where recombination
occurs but we, we don't see that. And even worse
we don't even know the genealogy that
relates to individuals even if they're kind
of closely related. Their second cousin most
people just ignore the tree that connects them.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So you don't know how far back in
time they were connected and you don't where recombination occurs.
so, the main problem is that you cannot
observe IBD directly from the data, you can
only observe a proxy of IBD, which is
IBS, identity by state. You can definitely detect
segments between individuals that are identical or roughly identical.
And so this is how an IBD algorithm works. We start by
scanning the chromosomes and finding long segments of IBS, and that
gives us some kind of candidate pool of IBD segments. And then we apply
various filters from these sets to extract the IBD segments.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And whose filters are varied, they depend on the
length of the segments, meaning that it's pretty unlikely to
have a very long IBS segment that was not generated
by a common ancestor. We have, we also apply a
filter for the frequency of the segment that
was inherited. If the segment is very, very
frequent in the population maybe it's not IB,
it's not IBD, it's just IBS, and that
arose to, to being fixed in the population
because maybe of natural selection or other, other
reasons. So frequency, quality of the segment, if
it contains many mutations then it's unlikely to
be IBD. We have a lot of
[UNKNOWN]
>> Yeah, it sounds like you really have to think a lot around how to make
sure that it's a true identity by descent
and not like you say, either coincidental or something
else. so let me make sure I even
understand this. the smaller the segment that, the smaller
the segment that appears to be commonly shared
the more likely it could be that it's just,
you know, a match of identity by state,
by chance with someone random in the population.
>> That's correct. So maybe I should
clarify the definition of IBD a little bit
because under the definition I gave actually
everyone is IBD everywhere, just because we all
have a common ancestry if you go far enough back in time. So when we
talk about IBD we usually restrict ourself
to the recent past, say, I don't know,
a few tens of generations, maybe a thousand years. And what, what's
beyond this point we, we're, we just don't have
the power to decide anymore if it's IBD or not. But
if you go, if you look small enough, everyone's IBD everywhere.